foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so there's a candidate for New
York Congress and he is representing a
highly sex positive political platform
and that means that he's trying to
abolish adultery laws legalize sex work
adultery loss wait are there yeah what
are the adultery laws that thou shalt
not cheat you can't have an affair
like legally legalize it's against the
law to see he wants to legalize sex work
but uh abolish adultery laws I'm sure
there's some wild [ __ ] on the books
that's like on the books but never
really enforced anything oh yeah that's
true that's true so like the Scarlet
letters that some people have get to be
taken off yeah you got to put the A on
your forehead whatever but that's his
whole campaign it's like all sex
positive that's his whole thing uh guess
what he did as a power move for his
publicity
I know about this already because I'm
from New York and it's like on it's hot
[ __ ] it was hilarious did he make a
porno and then like use that as a
campaign video I bet you he did I think
I saw this I thought it was a joke no
it's real oh you thought it was a joke
you made a video
oh it's real no way so this this is his
video The Hammer Johnny Sins
that's Johnny Sins that's a doctor I
know Johnny Johnny
[Applause]
I'm gonna be a resident this gets your
vote this kind of a [ __ ]
bro he made a sex tape with a porn
actress Nicole sage in order to show hey
man I'm just about to talk he's like hey
he's like I eat [ __ ] dog that's his
platform oh my god dude that bed is
weird as [ __ ] though let's see a stroke
if you got a good stroke
so everybody talks about like that his
sex tape's actually a little bit mid I
take it back
it's not kind of whack bro those jokes
are whack I can't vote for that dude
look I take it back those are shallow
pumps my boy it's a little lag it's 13
minutes long he looks like another thing
so that's dead fishing that's too long
of a video too long yeah we don't need
that much there's also a bad angle man
Anthony doesn't yeah yeah this is the
worst porn oh by the way I'm not
enjoying it at all usually he's hyped
for this stuff I'm not even yeah usually
I'm like hey what is this what does what
what do people on your side of the uh of
the world think of this this is wild I
mean we've seen some wild [ __ ] get done
oh Jesus that's funny as [ __ ] now now
that's funny
this is like a one bedroom somewhere
like where is this even shot they gotta
fire the director this is like a college
dorm I feel like it's a wasted
opportunity
she thrown it down we're just watching
this [ __ ] she's throwing it down he's
not reciprocating does he have good
chances to win I have no idea of all the
reasons for us to ever watch porn on
this show the fact that this is a
[ __ ] candidate yeah yeah dude this is
wild wasted opportunity reporting like
slogans on the wall
I'll bring rent down yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that would have been better whoa
hey yoamed up right now
yeah you're gonna put like a [ __ ]
campaign sticker on his ass cheek can't
answer your question yeah what do you
rate his [ __ ] Style hey look doggy style
that right there probably uh seven out
of ten right seven out of ten Seven's
pretty good man it's been a long time
since I watched porn with six other
dudes Jesus this is important it's a
campaign videos yeah it's a campaign
video it's been like two hours for me
yeah you think she's voting for him or
you think it's just a paid job for her
you know it's a paid gig for sure this
is this is not a passion project I don't
think whose house is this bro 4
000 a month apartment
they give so many questions wait so he
just dropped that on his like website
his campaign website or what I no on a
porn site you know I will say it's been
a long time since I've seen like an
average dick in a porn video you know
what I mean that guy look like yeah
average sized penis it was very white
though like a 16 inch long that just
like pounds and breaks somebody's back
you know you're saying he's like giving
hope to the common man I'm saying that's
a common man yeah what's he running for
uh he is running for congress
Manhattan Congressional candidate yeah
dude that's crazy he's breaking
boundaries has he mentioned his stance
on any other subjects besides doesn't
matter I vote for him yeah I I believe
that's his power thing all of it all of
it is based on like sex related stuff so
to be fair he really isn't just all talk
and I think that's that goes a long way
yeah he's a good initiative does that
like resonate with the New York the
average New Yorker that you think I
think every New Yorker is talking about
this video and be like we ain't voting
for this
it's like what's he doing
that's crazy but he has a porn crew that
takes off after this like he would have
my vote if she were dressed as a cop
he's like I'm all about [ __ ] the cops
that's some [ __ ] Talent involved not
just a regular ass sex tape that's true
yeah it is a missed opportunity is there
is there uh I wonder what like other
politicians think like what does AOC
have to say about
oh there is another opponent who is a
Republican and he said hey you gotta he
said you gotta do what you got to do oh
no you the media ignores everybody
that's not a Democrat anyway so
kind of kind of
that Republican was also like if a sex
tape about me comes out featuring a
underage person please remember I did it
for my camera
somebody said Anthony Weiner walked so
Mike idkis could run dude I'm just fine
I was thinking that damn I was like dude
if Anthony Weiner did some [ __ ] like
this he probably actually not well he
did he was like he did with like Andre
age person right I thought he was
sending dick pics to people or something
but then that was like the second one
because he got popped like four
different times yeah yeah I was
following it because I was like dude him
and prince Andrew are like my goats oh
my God
because they have the craziest stories
how did you guys yeah some people like
MJ you know this is Matt Gates is a
strong third for you is that his name no
Matt Gates is a senator or congressman
from uh Florida oh I'm not a game I
gotta look this guy I don't know he's
he's can we do an article about him in
that Community he's probably very highly
revered in that community in the go talk
Community yeah yeah
this guy's not married he doesn't have
kids oh no way dude that would be
actually even better and he still did
that I'd be like damn it oh he said that
men should not be required to support
biological children without prior
agreement well yeah he's anti-child
anti-child support like if the if the if
the woman has a child and he like man
who's the father says uh I don't want to
have this kid they should not be forced
to pay for that's dope which is an
interesting take yes dope is a good word
that's lit that's lit that's actually a
fairly nuanced approach I think I'm not
touching that one at all the third rail
for you yeah yeah prince Andrew cope I'm
not touching this actually yeah but that
one I'm not touching it no [ __ ] way
that's this guy's [ __ ] wild bro yeah
no it's [ __ ] average that's what he's
[ __ ] but um this is this is uh what
he looks like in case because all you
saw was his dick and ass he looks like
the penguin dude
who's his [ __ ] campaign manager it's
probably her hey is that a different
video that's a different background
different wall oh you want to see the
rest of the video they switch rooms we
didn't see the beginning it um for some
reason it jumps back in time like it's
like Pulp Fiction a little bit there's a
flash of how it starts so you're saying
it is Oscar worthy it might be yeah you
got to finish the whole thing damn dude
but yeah it's a little bit it's a I do
respect the power move of it but it's
badly executed I feel like it's just
like you know if you're gonna do it yeah
maybe he already felt like this is
enough because like he's already
stepping way out of his you know
political boundary maybe he shot the
porno and he's like I need a reason to
upload this publicly yeah and I need
good marketing so I'll run for Congress
oh yeah maybe Congress is like a
secondary thing but his real dream is
like porn work yeah he wants to be a
porn dude and then he's like watch I'm
gonna make my porno the most famous
porno most talked about in all of New
York watch and he's like and we watched
we watched that's so wild though to go
from the idea being conceived in his
head to like thinking it out talking to
some buddies he had to talk to some
people about it like I think I'm gonna
[ __ ] he's calling up Kim K and she's
like you should do it I think so you're
impressed by his execution I'm just
impressed that he actually did it as you
hold a water gun you're gonna vote for
him there's conviction there's so many
ways with so many steps to be like this
is an awful [ __ ] idea oh yeah there's
a lot of people that tell them you
should not do this oh yeah for sure he's
like watch watch I'ma [ __ ] this chicken
the worst [ __ ] room in the world of
all time it's mostly the set we have a
problem yeah because most of the worst
case scenario I bang a porn star that's
what happens for this guy yeah yeah
nothing happens to this dude for doing
this that's true you couldn't get a
camera B in there but now everybody saw
his wiener
[Laughter]
everybody has to show their wiener if
they're running for congress pull your
dicks out
let's see some dicks before you get my
vote stick out brother very New York of
you yeah so his name's Mike idkish I
don't know what his chances are they
don't look good they don't sound good
but he did a thing yeah he did do a
thing yeah no one knows the other
congressional candidates from New York I
don't know any of them not yet
it's good marketing yeah probably I
don't even know what they [ __ ] do
after half of politics like name
recognition it's like yeah people like
go to a voting booth they know like two
names like I think I heard of this dude
let me [ __ ] vote yeah it's good
branding a lot of it is just the [ __ ]
lawn signs to me yeah I got oh yeah I
know that name my neighbor had that on
his lawn you know easy Mike yes that's
the porno guy yeah he didn't have to do
this much but he said something about no
child support yes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]